if i put my hand in front of the beam a
large hadron collider
what would happen to my hand don't know
don't know don't know i oh gosh um
that's a good question i don't know is
the answer probably very bad for you
i don't know the total amount of energy
that will be distributed i don't know
the energy density not a good idea i
wouldn't recommend it
if i was to put my hand in the beam of
the large hadron collider what would
happen to my hand
certainly wouldn't advise doing that
and the
safety that we have implemented here is
such that there's
zero possibility you could ever do that
so let's make it a
theoretical experiment that you actually
did that the beam
itself is focused down very tightly it's
less than a millimeter across
extremely intense the actual energy
carried by the beam
is like an aircraft carrier in motion i
mean it's a massive amount of energy
there
so you really wouldn't want to put your
hand in there it'd make a hole straight
through it if i put my hand in front of
the beam in the large hadron collider
what would happen what would happen to
my hand right now nothing there's no
beam
when there's beam it would hurt
okay there's a there's a train going
through there at full speed basically
that's the amount of energy that there
is so yeah you would you would it would
hurt your hand quite a bit
but it's not just that tiny part of beam
the beam
or the proton beam is accompanied by
what's called a halo of electrons and
some muons as well they extend out quite
far
some of which can be you know meters
away
so there's an intense beam of particles
coming down that accompanies this
extremely intense part
so your whole body would be irradiated
you'd die pretty quickly i think that
the more it's going to burn right
through you basically it's going to burn
through that soft tissue we can already
you can already see it there's some
examples where they put
metal in front of various beams and you
can see the holes that it can make in it
so i'm sorry it would hurt it would hurt
a lot
i have to say i haven't really thought
about this very much i don't think it
would explode your hand i can't see any
mechanism for that to happen it'd be
more like a laser so a very intense
beam that would just go straight through
your hand and destroy anything in its
path
you